Todd Dasher thank you very much for
speaking with reason TV and for making
me a drink today you're welcome I'm glad
to be here so we are going to make what
cocktails that's called a Melanie's
pisco pipedream this particular cocktail
has one crucial ingredient which is raw
egg whites correct there's been some
controversy over the inclusion of raw
egg whites in drinks particularly at the
Pegu Club in New York where there was a
health inspector crackdown maybe you
could just tell me a little bit about
why it is that you include reg whites in
this drink what what function they serve
and why they seem to make people so
nervous I know exactly where this egg
came from I know when it came out of the
chicken I know the farmer that makes it
I know pretty much with the the chicken
ate that got there I know everything
about it I know I got this egg delivered
on Monday they were hatched on Saturday
by a farmer named Joel Salatin assault
Virginia I know exactly where I come
from I have no reason to be scared of
our eggs that's the first reason the
number two reason is I'm putting in so
much acid into it it's gonna kill
anything that may have happened to it so
that's the reason that I believe there's
a scare about it and I've up until that
happened at Pegu I'd never heard of a
scare about it you know we they want us
to market on our menu may contain
undercooked ingredients but we haven't
had a problem that I know of in American
history no one's ever gotten sick out of
drinking a cocktail with an egg in it
now they may have been sick because they
drank too many cocktails with eggs in it
but not just because a cocktail with egg
in it so the reason that we do it gives
it's an old-style cocktail it's called a
fizz technically when you use an egg
white it's been around since the 1800s
you know there's references and to dr.
Jerry Thomas's book about using egg
whites and cocktails so it's not a new
thing it's a completely old thing it's
just going back to what bartending was
hundreds of years ago so I added and the
reason is that it is for texture in
cocktails mouthfeel yeah a lot of
bartenders such as yourself and the guys
at the Pegu Club have attracted
attention for kind of doing something
new or you I guess you might say doing
something old again doing it old
everything comes back in fashion you
know could you talk a little bit about
the places where in
runs up against just uncertainty about
what the law price I guess you know it
started five or six years ago I had this
harebrained idea to start making bidders
and they were on the market here in
Virginia and there were two bidders
there was Angostura
and there was P showed and that's it
but like when I would go to other
markets like if I go to New Orleans or
New York or things you'd see all these
amazing bottles on the bar and they had
lemon that rhubarb they have all these
different flavors and then you know I
started looking and I said oh I could
buy them I could buy them online and
find them someplace but then I said it
wouldn't be better if you just make it
yourself so you know I went online as
Thank You Al Gore for the internet you
know I went online and uh figured out oh
I can do this myself so then I just
figured out start making all these
different combinations and things that I
find out oh well it may not be legal to
do this because it goes back to the
infusing things outside the ball and put
it back into the bottle I have a buddy
in a San Francisco named Niall white who
the ABC board came in and dumped all his
stuff they just came in it was like two
weeks ago they just came into the bar
said are you making these he said yes
and they just started dumping everything
out and it's a massive passion and time
consuming thing to make bitters just to
to make bitters at the bare minimum
three days the way I make it
so to this point I'm not a hundred
percent sure what the law is in Virginia
I would like to think I'm not breaking
the law you know I'm not selling the
bitters I I think what I'm doing more is
kind of like a chef would cook you know
people talk about how cool it is to go
to the chef's table this is the original
chef's table what do you think about it
because everything's done right in front
of you and that transparency adds an
additional element of choice for the
consumer they see what's going on they
can say well I'm not comfortable with
that I'm okay with that
you mean people can be adult to make
their own decisions I do mean that
that's amazing they're amazing
what a concept and that's something
that's a big issue I would think in your
industry in general you know adults
choosing to imbibe alcoholic beverages
on their on their own drinks and I mean
you can make the decision if you if you
don't want the egg you know I won't make
it a cocktail you don't want it the egg
now will I make this cocktail without
the egg it's not the same cocktail I can
make it for you and I'll be glad to do
it but you're gonna say oh this doesn't
taste right
course not because it's not the right
cocktail but yeah choices can be made
you can choose to drink or not to drink
you can choose a walk cross street or
not to do it you are operating here in
Virginia and there are some additional
complications that come with working in
this state including the state's alcohol
Control Board can you talk a little bit
about what the challenges are there and
and how that affects the way you do
business
yes can I shake my cocktail first please
do okay so where were we
Virginia I love Virginia was born and
raised in Virginia with the elementary
school junior high school high school in
college of Virginia I love it but some
of the ABC laws are a bit out of date
and there's laws in the book and
everything has to go through the state
and it's a little bit outdated this is a
prime example much of Pisco was not
available in state of Virginia I had to
petition the state special order it then
the lady Melanie who is the maker of it
has to fulfill a special order to the
state she has to send a case the state
and then I get it and there was about a
six month process to get it so it's a
little outdated and it's a little hard
to get a hold of stuff but generally
it's a fair state and you know there's
things on the docket now and I think in
the state Senate that uh is talking
about privatization of ABC's source Aden
I would kind of be down with that if it
would open up more spirits coming
through I mean you see we don't have a
ton of spirits here just because of the
space but like Eve our other restaurant
you know we have lots of space and I
would like to get some really cool stuff
but right now I can't so we're now
putting on so this is a black pepper and
Meyer lemon reduction which it doesn't
have much color but it does add a lot of
flavor to the bottom of our to the
cocktail and it's just going to sit on
top and as it goes through its gonna add
a little bit of black pepper spice to it
and it's gonna rest on the bottom a
little bit so the last drop will be a
little different in flavor than the
first few you know was still an
uncertain time with things we're doing
you know I have cocktails that I use
tobacco I have cocktails that I use wood
chips you know with innovations trying
to make new cocktails and make
interesting cocktails you know you
wonder if the legality of it if you're
start to do things and then someone's
gonna come back and say oh that's not
legal or you can't put that in there or
you know it's like the whole Ferran
adrià of what you think you know the
only way to innovate is to do things you
know so far out of the box that it
becomes the norm like el boi use food
did you know hopefully the bartending
movement is moving in that same way
where you can use things it's not just
you know out of a bottle to to make new
things you know and hopefully you know
hopefully we're not breaking a law the
image of you know enforcers coming in
and pouring out bottles seems very
prohibition-era it seems like something
we should have left in the past
yeah it's surprising to find it today it
definitely happens today you know I kind
of joked that this is a speakeasy you
know we didn't start out to do it as a
speakeasy but I think you know the press
caught a hold of and you know then it
was a stick and things like that yeah
I'm just waiting for the coppers to bust
through any second and hopefully they
come in and say oh this is fine but I'm
sure at some point you know they're
gonna come in and want to see it and I
think by dropping alcohol in the bitters
I think I'm okay and if the state says
no you can't do it then I won't be doing
it
thank you very much Todd Cheers that is
really really good
you're so alive too and and I've lived
to tell the tale